[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima we are here
at the big little lies Emmy for your
consideration event talking to the cast
about what we might see in season two we
just have a lot of anger that we need
some help controlling there's a line
between passion and rage and we cross
that out
the scenes between Celestin Perry were
so intense and so powerful how did you
kind of unwind once you got home from
those normally I can step back into my
family life in a very easy way but it
was hard and I would come home and
luckily I have a partner who's artistic
and so he understands what it takes to
support that and he's I came home to
loving arms you know someone that would
hold me and I was really upset at times
really damaged and really upset and
physically and emotionally drained and
in pain my neck to killya do so but
luckily I you know I have that at home
and I had the ability and I also have
people I can talk to and get get it out
people are obsessed the fandom is crazy
they're already calling for season two
what would you want season two to look
like to entail it would just want it to
continue on with the complexity and with
the truths and with I suppose that
entering into the female psyche could it
be a completely different story
different characters you think with the
same cast I don't know I mean we love
working together and watching Laura and
Reese and Shaye and Zoe and all of them
do their thing
and being privy to that I just you know
we all knew it was special when we were
doing
it but fit to be embraced in this way is
also spectacular would we want to work
together again absolutely would we
explore options for that to happen
absolutely
[Music]